savait qu'il fallait s'inquiéter mais à
quel point la nouvelle loi sur la
sécurité nationale bouleverse le
canadien installé à hong kong depuis 16
ans nous avons protéger son identité
parce qu'il craint des représailles
le but c'est qu'il pourra pas pour que
tout aille pour qu'elles bloguaient plus
de protest site un opinion qui disent
pas publiquement les canadiennes ne sont
plus en sécurité en croit cet ancien
diplomate à pékin selon lui les
relations entre le canada et la chine
risque de s'envenimer encore plus rien
de rassurant pour les trois cent mille
canadiens à nkon fort on craint déjà le
gouvernement trudeau a annoncé la
suspension du traité d'extradition avec
un code ainsi que ses exportations
matériel militaire et devient
stratégique adopté en grande pompe par
la chine mardi dernier
cette nouvelle loi sur la sécurité
nationale en kung reçoit déjà son lot de
critiques et d'opposition selon charles
braine cette législation méprise les
libertés du peuple dan cole et viole ses
obligations internationales
pékin impose donc son pouvoir sur un
comme un territoire en théorie semi
autonome où règnent depuis 1997
le principe d' un pays deux systèmes
avant la nouvelle loi
j'avais encore l'intention de le rester
pour lui difficile de s'imaginer fonder
une famille dans les conditions
actuelles
à son avis d'autres canadiens songe à
quitter le territoire et le staff coach
6 pts
hong kong returns selon ce professeur en
études asiatiques
il ne fait aucun doute que les
manifestations et la violence prendront
de l'ampleur
le retour au calme n'est pas pour
bientôt
déjà en kohn a été le théâtre de
nouvelles manifestations cette semaine
avec varrault rester de présenter comme
louable en fille pourtant le risque est
réel pour ces manifestants qu'ils
s'exposaient de nouvelles sanctions
d'après la nouvelle loi la prison à vie
pourra être infligée pour les crimes
contre la sécurité nationale commis à
alcon et si gabriel garran radio canada
toronto